what's up you guys
movie retrospective time talking about
tim burton today yeah mars attacks
i kind of feel like this movie
i don't know i think it's better um i'm
sure it's like a lot better received now
than it was at the time
uh but i still feel like it got it kind
of gets like some mixed reviews like a
lot of people do think that this was
like his last good movie and then the
ones after that were just kind of meh um
some people love it some people hate it
it's really like an interesting film in
his canon i think i thought everybody
loved it when it came out my dad loved
this movie i loved it when i i saw in
the theater actually when it came out in
1996. my dad grew up seeing war of the
worlds you know just like me you know
when i was a kid watching he watched it
when he was a kid wore the worlds and
this is like it's like war of the worlds
but funny
yeah it's it's good i kind of feel like
what maybe happened no the thing about
it was that i mean the reviews at the
time were mixed some people really loved
it some people really didn't like it
um it barely made its money back uh so
it was considered kind of a failure
matter of fact
the reason that tim burton you know how
tim burton was gonna go like and do uh
the batman movie with nicholas cage in
it yeah
the uh the reason he didn't get to do
that was because they or
superman yeah that's what i meant yeah
um the reason he didn't get to do that
was because uh this movie didn't do as
well as they anticipated so they were
like punishing him like the studio was
finishing him yeah because uh this
didn't uh come out the way i kind of
feel like okay so this was 1996. this
was the same year that independence day
came out now independence day had come
out in summer you know in july of 1996
and this came out christmas
so
the problem was when they were first
working on mars attacks which like i
said i'll get into the history of it in
a little bit because that's actually
kind of interesting
um
i guess the makers of independence day
found out that they were doing mars
attacks which is essentially the same
story
although it's wildly different in tone
but they were worried that
uh you know independence day was worried
because they said well if mars attacks
comes out first we're gonna look like
we're ripping it off but then mars
attacks was like well if you know
independence day comes out first then
it's gonna look like we're doing a
parody of it even though we've been
talking about doing this movie since the
1980s
so as it happened they kind of like
spaced them out and i feel like a lot of
people loved independence day which i'm
not a huge fan of and
everybody well this movie mars attacks
is a black comedy and those are always a
hard sell
um this was parodying
a movie like independence day tim burton
even called this he said we didn't
actually know that independence day was
going to come out the same year that
they were even working on it it was just
like a coincidence um and he's like but
you could totally see this as like the
quote-unquote mad magazine version of
independence day where it was like a
parody of it it's like we don't really
mean for that to happen they just happen
to come out around the same time but
that's maybe
a little bit why it didn't
fly so well i think if it was released
now it would be a lot better received
because i think people would get it more
black comedies still in 1996 were not
really
like i said they were kind of a hard
sell like a lot of people
weren't really into them
i don't know if it was released today it
might not even be noticed
because they're they're putting stuff
out nobody even notices it now
well yeah that's special effects sold
this movie when it came out the special
effects were real good for the time i
love the martians in this yeah and the
the the tone is really good
it's
it's it's supposed to be taking place in
the 90s
but it's obviously the 50s the army yes
the army is the 50s it's 50 all the
equipment is from the 50s
the uh the aliens are from the 50s yeah
everything looks like a 50s sci-fi yeah
the the tone of the movie is it's war of
the worlds mixed with invaders from mars
and mars and
mars needs women and that that's in it
too it's just
it's just homaging a lot of classic
horror
horror movies about aliens and being
attacked by mars from the 5th this way
the 50s were yeah i mean yeah stuff like
it conquered the world and that was kind
of like a lower budget and it uh
it's it's filled with a lot of moral
lessons in there that people don't i
don't know if they catch it or not maybe
they probably do it's just
it it's basically war of the worlds no
matter what mankind throws at these
aliens it doesn't work
they throw bureaucrats at the aliens
they don't work
they throw politics at the aliens it
doesn't work science and reason doesn't
work
uh military pacifism doesn't work uh of
military hyper aggression doesn't work
nothing works i get these against these
damn aliens
so it doesn't even really matter what
your
mindset is or your political philosophy
or anything the aliens just find a way
to just go eh you know
even nuclear weapons don't work you know
that's one of my favorite scenes of the
movie actually where they i wish that
where they do like shoot a nuke at the
ship and they just have this little
thing that looks like a little ooga horn
with like a little red thing and it just
flies out and it sucks in the thing and
then they suck it in like it's helium
yep
doesn't matter if you're a premier
pretty bimbo you get killed doesn't
matter if you're a handsome hero you get
killed doesn't matter if you get if
you're michael j fox getting cucked out
you get killed doesn't matter if you're
a fat dude from the trailer park in the
army you get killed everybody gets
killed the only thing that can defeat
these aliens is a stupid [ __ ]
yodeling off a damn record album totally
random
yeah so it's basically burning up all
the sacred cows
yes that's exactly what it's just doing
there i mean because much like war of
the worlds it's kind of like like you
said they did everything or the world's
almost like subverted the trope a little
bit too where you had like all these
heroes and like normally in a 50s sci-fi
movie like you would defeat the aliens
at the end but the only thing that
defeated them was essentially like an
accident yeah uh and that's the same
thing that happens in this movie is that
accidentally somebody discovers that
that slim whitman song makes their heads
explode and that's what ends up
defeating them nothing prior to that did
it i think it subverts uh
the uh the
the original accident though
in war of the worlds
it says that microbes kill the aliens
yeah all right
but then on top of that it says this
happened because of god's wisdom well
that was in the movie that was well i
guess it was a little bit in the book
but it was it was leaned harder yeah so
yeah i guess they went more divine
intervention
whereas this one was just like a stupid
fluke like the humans only won because
of dumb luck not so much divine wisdom
it was
because they were layering in that god
and nature were the same thing so kind
of like you know
the natural order the wisdom of the
natural order of the universe every
predator is kept in check by something
that's i think what they're talking
about you can call it god if you want
but we know you want you we know you
believe in god so go ahead and call it
god
that's that was that was the original
uh a concept
this well because h.g wells was an
atheist so you know right but then as i
think so i think war of the worlds movie
probably
i think h.g wells would have
probably accepted that that yeah
probably yeah you know call it god if
you want that yeah basically um but this
one says no no [ __ ] all that it's just
random [ __ ] it it's just country music
yeah country music just in particular a
slim whitman song
called i think it's called indian love
call yeah right yeah slim whitman
what's that like destroyed the alien
spot it just with that yodeling yeah
and like i said it was just and it was
just random dumb luck that that got
discovered so there was no divine wisdom
or [ __ ] or anything like that that's
what i mean that's what i mean about
this being like
a black comedy and honestly i was
reading there's a really great uh
article on collider
about uh why mars attacks is good and
why people should respect it more and
it's really really good and it's really
well written and they said the awesome
thing about this movie is that it's one
of the most mean-spirited
big budget studio films they'd ever seen
in the sense that
every single person they get this huge
like ensemble cast of like all these
super famous people every single one of
them is an idiot and they get killed in
like really really embarrassing ways
like after they've only been in like a
scene or two and it's almost kind of
like
like
rubbing it in the audience's face faces
as well like a little bit it's it's no
matter who you're gonna project yourself
to based on your personal belief systems
no matter who you think you are who you
could identify in this movie they're
going to die
yeah it's not going to matter like for
instance uh um
the president and this [ __ ] local con
man is kind of like tiger king is both
played by the same guy by jack
all right
they're drawn parallels between
politicians and con men that they're the
same thing they're just the only
difference really is is the class
between them and they both die trying to
apply their trade yeah the president is
trying to
uh
makes he's trying he's trying to be
middle of the road and worry about what
the people think
he's not trying to start a war even
though a war has already been started on
him that's just ridiculous [ __ ] you know
what i mean he's trying to play politics
with
a force that is like a force of nature
it doesn't even politics aren't even in
this even in even in these aliens
[ __ ] consciousness it's just
destruction you know and there's not
even any reason or logic to any of it
that's what i was going to say it's like
that's another thing that i love about
this project and your reasoning
is that even in the 50s movies like when
aliens attacked they usually had a
reason like we want some resources on
your planet or we eat humans or whatever
in this one they're just jerks yep they
just think it's hilarious they just
think it's funny to like [ __ ] with us
yeah um and like make it you know they
they come here and then like they
pretend we come in peace and then they
just start like death writing everybody
and it's like psych and then they're
like oh we're sorry we didn't mean it
was a cultural misunderstanding and then
they're like
we did it again yeah yeah
you dumb [ __ ]
they're just like [ __ ] with us which
i think is one of the best things i
don't know if there's another movie like
that where it shows like the aliens come
here just just to kill us and do [ __ ]
up [ __ ] does for shits and giggles yeah
but that's essentially what they do that
was another thing that that collider
article said they said uh they said this
this movie is like if you were uh held
captive by aliens that were or like the
dudes from jackass that's like basically
yeah that's basically what they are yep
yep so the the president dies trying to
be political all right and come to an
agreement
and then jack nicholson's other
character that he's not a con man he's
like he's like a uh
he's a casino owner yeah you know right
an investor guys kind of like it's kind
of like uh the tiger king he looks like
tiger king trusting tiger king and lemmy
from motorhead
because he's very sparkly yeah he's
always got a different wig and he's got
it always got a different wig on it and
he dies at the top of a hotel holding
this big investors meeting and he's
trying to
get a new casino together and in the
background the aliens are just [ __ ]
blowing the whole [ __ ] whole world
and he's just i don't worry about it
even later on people are going to want
to roll those dice yeah
and you know it's just kind of funny how
it's just showing that these two
kind of alpha type dudes of very
different
i guess you could say class levels i
guess
we're both totally oblivious to [ __ ]
just
impending annihilation as if it would
all work out
the president thought it would all work
out we'll come to an agreement it'll be
all right what are the people going to
say what's he worried about that for
yeah you've got a couple of days left to
[ __ ] repel this alien invasion we
worry about the people's opinions on it
you know we should have a town meeting
yeah that's what his [ __ ] advisor
said well the funny thing
is that
like i said the whole cause i kind of
feel like i've read a couple reviews of
this movie where i think
maybe some people misunderstood like
when the aliens when the martians first
land and there's the big thing in the in
uh nevada
and all the hippies are there and stuff
and they come out and they seem like
they're friendly and they have the
translator and the you know the they're
like ah
and then they're like uh we come in
peace and everybody's like whoo we
coming they come in peace and then he
sets off the dove and then that seems to
like set the martians off and then they
start killing everybody
and it's very funny the way everybody is
just kind of like well maybe they maybe
dubs mean something different like on
mars and maybe like they're willing to
give them the benefit of the doubt yeah
because then the martians come out and
say oh we're sorry it was a cultural
misunderstanding but people don't seem
to i've seen some reviews that they
they think the martians did come in
peace at first they absolutely did not
they absolutely did not and they just
came here to [ __ ] everybody up yeah and
the president and the president had
forgiven them from destroying an entire
[ __ ]
rock concert full of people out of the
desert
uh it destroyed congress uh did all
kinds of stuff on multiple events he'd
been wiping out everything they wiped
out he wiped out france and his friend
in france and he still tried to make
peace with him what are we doing put her
there
the alien [ __ ] shook his head and the
[ __ ] robot handed him stabbed him in
the back and the [ __ ] red flag came
into the bar and they salute the dead
president now they were the
international side of the donut
there was absolutely
absolutely no intention of [ __ ]
making peace that's not what they were
for like i said they were they were
essentially just [ __ ]
they were just [ __ ] they were
trolling there was no reason nope um you
know they came here like i said they
kidnapped sarah jessica parker and her
chihuahua poppy yeah and switch their
heads for no reason for no reason just
because they think it's funny yeah they
kidnapped pierce brosnan who had just
been in like the james bond movie and
they made him just a hand and they made
him just a head and like all they had
all his body parts no reason no they
just did that because they could and
because they thought it was hilarious
yeah i mean some of my favorite [ __ ] is
just them in the ship with their little
red panties on like hanging around in
the spaceship in their underwear
and they're just like running around
with all these like people that they've
kidnapped that they're just doing these
[ __ ] up experiments on like i said
there's no reason there's no scientific
anything they're just doing it because
they're dicks and the internet and the
the language translator translated what
they said and i think that is what they
said they just said something yeah half
breeds and that and then later on about
what was it uh uh
the dark of this way dark or the smoking
does
mows like a harvest yeah
yeah that's exactly what they said
though well actually one of my favorite
scenes other than uh you know a couple
of the one that i just mentioned was
that when they're doing the huge
destruction at the end they actually
just to be funny they have like little
boom boxes that are playing the
translator they're carrying the
translator yeah and it says don't run we
are your friends like i said they're
just yeah they're just being jerks yeah
don't run don't uh while they're
shooting everything while they're
shooting
so like i said they're essentially just
[ __ ] yeah it had good special
effects the guns shot up
shot out down green
lightning bolts that would vaporize you
and turn you into a green
a green skeleton or a red skeleton red
skeleton
which is there that's called that's
shouting out to uh
uh looking um
uh [ __ ]
war of the worlds series where they were
shooting red stuff and green stuff and
people just melting and skeletons and
yeah yeah i knew exactly what they were
talking about yeah so if i don't know if
a lot of people know this but the um
mars attacks the movie
is actually based on and this might be
the only movie in history that can say
this was actually based on a series of
trading cards
from tops
now tops uh prior to like all through
the you know early part of the 20th
century they'd done baseball cards
that's kind of what they were known for
but then the early 1960s they did this
they wanted to do this kind of like more
horror themed or like subversive set so
they did two of them they did one called
dinosaurs attack
and they did one called mars attacks now
the cards that you could buy like i said
they're just like in the wax pack with
the bubble gum and [ __ ] like that had
these awesome
[ __ ] oil paintings if you have any of
them i think they're highly highly
collectible these days um but the art on
them is really really cool that's where
the design of the martians came from
that's not a tim burton design that's
not that's essentially what they looked
like on the cards and they wanted to
replicate that look as close as possible
these the cards were like way darker
than the movie ended up being i mean
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] happened on this
on these cards so predictably back in
1962 like the kids loved them because
they're like all right it's wiping out
the whole [ __ ] you know it's wiping
out the whole world and they were really
gory and [ __ ]
and uh predictably like you know people
parents and [ __ ] like that were like
well we can't have that and like you
know they kind of had to pull them in
the end they were for what movie it
wasn't it wasn't a movie it was an
original
just series of trading cards it was like
a story all right but it was all trading
cards it was there was no movie it was
based on there was no existing ip that
it was based on it was completely
original
and like i said the paintings if you you
and you can see them online they're
really really cool
how do i search for it um just put mars
attacks tops trading cards t-o-p-p-s um
and you'll be able to see them like i
said
it's 1962 62. so if you still have them
like i said uh because i know some
people do have them they're very very
collectible and i think like you could
it's probably like a couple of grand
like to even buy them nowadays um but
the art is beautiful and tim burton
uh really likes the look of those cards
so he wanted to replicate the look of
that as closely as possible and actually
if you see some of the cards he did
actually replicate
you know the opening scene with all the
cows on fire like running down that was
one of the cards okay and he
specifically won and it's funny because
he said we went through
so many drafts of the script and every
time we turned in a new draft the
producer said take out the burning cows
we can't have burning cows and he's like
but we just kept leaving it in there
right and he's like and they kept like
complaining and he's like i did it like
eight times not tim burton but like the
writer and he's like i did it like eight
times and he's like look if the cows are
still in there next time you're fired
and he left the cows in there and they
fired him
but they still left a bit there right
which i thought was like super funny
because tim burton was like well the
reason it's like the whole reason they
wanted us to take it out that was the
reason we wanted to get there it's like
that's [ __ ] awesome but it was like
one of the cards they wanted to
replicate one of the cards with all the
burning cows like running down the
[ __ ] stampede and so so they finally
they won that fight just for like war of
attrition and they just like left it in
there but yeah if you see like a lot of
like like i said that's where the um
the design of the martians came from
from those cards they look almost
exactly like they look in the movie
now originally tim burton um he had done
ed wood just before this which probably
my favorite uh film of his 1994 and he
got nominated for oscars and [ __ ] like
that so he thought this would be the
good one to do next because it's almost
like homaging
the edward style of movies now this
movie too
was actually in there were ideas for
this floating around back in the 80s
you know who was first attached to this
project was alex cox who is actually
better for like repa man sid and nancy
uh he was the one that came up with the
idea i want to make a movie from the
tops trading cards the mars attacks ones
and he wrote a treatment of it and it
kind of got picked up i think it was
orion or something like that and then it
just never got made and it just sort of
wanted to turn around or develop in hell
or whatever and then tim burton got
interested in it uh later on but how
weird would that have been if like alex
cox would have made this i can't imagine
what that would have been like but
originally
tim burton wanted the martians to be
stop motion uh obviously because he had
done nightmare before christmas and he
was really into stop motion and he
thought that it would be a good homage
to ray harryhausen at like you know the
old b movies
but uh the studio were like that's gonna
cost too much money they're trying to
keep it under 70 million or 80 million
or something like that they're like
we're not spending any more than that
you're gonna have to do cgi he was like
i don't really want to do cgi but then
um they got ilm industrial light and
magic
um to do
uh like a test with and they made like a
scene like with the aliens and stuff and
they showed it to tim burton and he was
just like oh my god that's amazing uh
okay we can do that now because the
aliens in this really do look awesome
yeah i'm good i mean they're very
they're very clearly cgi but the whole
thing is the movie is supposed to look
he's like i wanted the effects to look
fake or like 50s
um you know he's trying to homage that
time period so they didn't have to look
realistic
um and i think they did a really good
job i mean the like the look of it is
iconic yeah and we have to talk too
about the
the earth girl disguise yeah that they
do at one point in the movie that was
lisa marie who obviously was uh tim
burton's girlfriend at the time she also
played vampira and there's one
at the time uh she might have been i
can't remember
but uh she was great she's like only in
one scene
but that one where she comes down like
as an earth person even though she
clearly looks completely bizarre and i
love that everybody just acts like it's
completely a normal situation even
though she's like she doesn't talk she's
got this huge like [ __ ] four feet of
hair and she walks all like weird and
like gliding and stuff and everybody's
just like a skateboard or something
they're pulling it i think they
pretending to walk it's uh um they said
it was like a moving sidewalk
situation is what they had like
underneath her
one thing they said too was that they
said she was a real trooper because
one uh they had to sew her into that
dress so she couldn't pee or anything
like that like while they were shooting
it
also that wig she had to wear was
actually two wigs like you know cobbled
together
they said it weighed so much that it
essentially like put a hole in her head
and she still has a scar like to this
day they said it was really really heavy
so they said they were having a really
hard time like with the moving sidewalk
situation in the wig situation because
it kept like you know and it was kept
they thought they were afraid it was
gonna like break her neck because it was
it was so heavy and they were trying to
move her around like that but they said
you know she said afterward yeah it was
torture but it was like you know really
fun and she really was glad doing that
and honestly
that is such a great character we were
at a horror convention a few years ago
ago and saw somebody cosplay that and it
looked fantastic
i think i saw i think it was one maybe
it was uh rupaul's drag race and i think
they somebody did that outfit and it
looked like amazing that's like so
[ __ ] it's so cool but yeah it's it's
hilarious how many
famous people they got in this man like
other than jack nicholson you know glenn
close plays the first lady natalie
portman plays their daughter she's very
young i had forgotten she was in it too
michael j fox michael j fox is it gets
killed pretty much everybody gets killed
uh jack black and this was actually
before jack black was famous i think he
was
um i think he'd done like some theater
and some [ __ ] like that like he was kind
of known in some circles but i think
this was like the first big movie that
he was in he's the army kid he wasn't
fat yet
yeah it's just it was a bit chubby but
that was it was weird like seeing him
like that yeah uh pam grier was in this
like rod steiger yeah uh just [ __ ]
everybody
tom jones and i love that tom jones was
one of the people that survived the
martian invasion just because he knew
how to fly a plane yeah
and and all the deer
and they come out of the cave
and he like and he's like doing this and
he puts his arm up in a [ __ ] eagle
it's funny because well tom jones i
don't know if again i don't know if like
this is widely known or not but he's
welsh and i actually i think he's from
uh he's not from cardiff i don't think
but he's from swansea i think i want to
say he's from swansea and um but i could
be wrong about that so i went to the
town that he was from and holy [ __ ] do
they love tom jones and wales which i
guess you know there's not a huge amount
of people that are famous that are from
welsh anthony hopkins like catherine
zeta jones uh people like that gene
loves jezebel but they're not they're
not really that famous manic street
preachers uh you know they're probably
more famous but uh so i guess like when
somebody is internationally famous like
tom jones especially somebody that was
like such a staple of vegas culture so
you know they're super super proud that
he's from there so i just thought that
was super funny but uh but yeah so i so
i liked that they had that i will say
that i think
i think maybe like this could have been
slightly funnier i will say that
i will say that some of the scenes i
feel like some of the jokes
um
could have been like amped up a little
bit
but that's pretty minor criticism you
know what i'm saying i liked it i
thought yeah it's a lot of fun it's a
lot of fun i wouldn't change anything
yeah it's classic
yeah and like i said it's it seems like
it's gotten kind of like you know it has
a mixed reaction like some people really
love it some people are like hey you
know it's i was watching uh nostalgia
critic did a thing on it and he's just
he thought it was funny like it had
funny bits but it was like a lot of
wasted potential he's like you had all
these really famous people and they
could have done a lot more with it but
in the days though the in the days they
weren't as famous as they are now though
we took some of them weren't we took
those people for granted back then the
thing about it too is that they had to i
mean the original version of this script
uh had a lot more characters and had a
lot more destruction
uh but because they only got 70 80
million
um you know what i mean they're like
well we you know we had scenes where
like all like whole other cities got
destroyed like around the world and we
couldn't really do that so it's like we
had to kind of confine the action to you
know new york vegas uh you know and
washington dc with just like a couple
scenes in like paris and i think they
did they did that one like where the
aliens were in front of the taj mahal
like posing and then like the aliens
like blew it up and they were like we
blew it up you know so they did that but
originally it was gonna have much more
of that but honestly like i said this
isn't
you know your traditional
independence day type alien invasion
movie independence day was more of a
serious you know it took itself
seriously you know here comes the aliens
we all got to band together to fight it
this was like
making fun of not specifically that
movie but was making fun of that genre
you know what i mean so i don't think it
had that way though not in a bad way so
yeah like i said it's it's a parody it's
a loving parody of
not only like 50s b sci-fi movies and
blockbusters in general it was also kind
of parodying like 70s disaster movies
like with the ones with like all-star
casts yeah where you know like all these
people like oh my god that famous person
and they got killed you know what i mean
so he was kind of like homaging that a
little bit as well
um and honestly it's like the the
[ __ ] distinctive look of it it's like
like i said i love the martians i just i
don't know i just love the the look of
it yeah
i wouldn't change anything uh i think
the movie's a lot of fun it's got a lot
of good characters in it [ __ ] that [ __ ]
happens to all of them but it's kind of
funny um
it's got good villains the the
the martians even though they're cg
they look great to me you know i love
their eyes like the way their eyes move
they're just kind of
cartoony and fun but what's funny is
that they are kind of effective villains
uh
you know what i mean they're not scary
per se but they're just
you look at them go yeah those dudes are
[ __ ] you know they they they work
because they don't give a [ __ ] they
don't give a [ __ ] they just came to
earth they just came to earth to [ __ ]
[ __ ] up they don't want anything from us
they were laughing they do stuff they
start laughing yeah they're like
high-fiving each other like like hey
good one you know what i mean so like i
said that's that's kind of like like
what i think is the best aspect of the
movie is that there is absolutely no
reason behind these aliens coming here
they're just [ __ ] yeah and i just
love that yeah and they subvert that
whole thing and i mean they're
scientists you know played by the dude
who was [ __ ] pierce brazil here's
brosnan yeah he's like well it's obvious
that they've come here look at the size
of this because they
said they've come here uh across the
gulfs of space they're a superior
culture so they're and with real high
intelligence so therefore they should be
peaceful and uh we should have no
problem with it no it's not what
happened
project projecting
projecting your values system on these
things you haven't even met these things
yet they show up they [ __ ] zap the
[ __ ] dove they open fire on the crowd
they just [ __ ] burn it and then they
go oh yeah
and then they pretend that it was just a
misunderstanding and then they do it
again they didn't laugh at me
because she dumbassed the spell for it
so uh
some people are like oh well you know
but it's true though if they can get
here then they'd be peaceful no no
yeah not necessarily you don't really
know what they're what their culture is
like i said they could be just a bunch
of like guys from jackass yeah or you
know because just because you're smart
doesn't mean you're a nice person see
something from predator predator one
that might be a reality that these
things [ __ ] can come here and hunt
you and they go well they would be
advanced though
look
they don't have to build those ships
they might be be able to buy those
rednecks go out and kill [ __ ] they don't
they don't they don't make trucks or
four-wheelers or anything they just buy
them well they might be part of some
kind of
you know galactic civilization of
planets that trade with each other and
they just might be
basically dicks that can get their hands
on that kind of technology travel around
[ __ ] [ __ ] up
yeah which like i said as far as i know
i don't really know if there's been
another sci-fi movie with that premise
i guess well where the specifically the
aliens were attacking earth earth were
just jerks and like they didn't have any
reason and like i said you could even
say like you know building on what you
just said was that these martians might
just be
like they might not there might be like
actually nice intelligent martians back
on mars these are just [ __ ] that
decided to go like cruising and it's
like hey let's go in here it's like you
know it's like rednecks going to tip
cows or something like that there was a
whole armada of them so that's true and
i i i would think it was they were just
they were taking them i know but i'm
just saying like in you know in theory
you just don't know it could be like
that that could just be these might not
even be like the best examples of the
civilization right these might just be
like a faction of douche bags and in in
a situation like it's a star wars type
galaxy there's nothing you look at the
sand people the sand people were just
lived out in the desert but they had
weapons and [ __ ] plasma [ __ ]
looking weapons and that they didn't
make they must have bought those well
they could probably get a spaceship too
and leave
yeah yeah and then you got [ __ ] sand
people coming to your house
the [ __ ] is this you know
so yeah i don't don't
we don't know what the situation is with
uh out out in space yeah it's always
pretty better to proceed with caution
right
although like i said in the situation
that you see in mars attacks i'm not
really sure that there's much that we
could have done no i mean you know what
i mean it's like the people like
everybody that's in it are idiots that's
true
but
being not an idiot that didn't really
seem to help either because like i said
the the aliens weren't here for any
other purpose other than to just like to
kill everybody yeah well they they went
ahead and they had superior technology
they went ahead and [ __ ] showed you
smart dumb ugly good looking it didn't
matter yeah didn't matter what you
believed they killed everybody
yeah and like i said the only people
that survived was just kind of through a
fluke or like dumb luck like the only
reason they survived was because they
figured out the song or because they
they didn't really like you know the one
guy that um
you know that left the casino you know
he lived because he's like [ __ ] this
casino i'm leaving to like you know
you know find my family so people were
kind of doing more personal [ __ ] or like
you know lucas has character who said
you know [ __ ] my parents joedon baker
was the uh dad by the way and he's just
kind of like you know [ __ ] you guys in
the trailer park i'm gonna go get
grandma and he and him and grandma ended
up kind of like killing everybody but
like i said it was just sort of like an
accident yeah but everybody that was
like in authority or thought that they
knew what was going on or thought they
knew the solution to the problem yeah
didn't make it all got killed
you know what i mean whether they were
smart or stupid or whatever they just
all got killed and like i said i think
that's what uh people mean saying this
like a really mean
movie but it's mean-spirited for a
purpose it's supposed to be a black
comedy it's a you know it's a parody in
the face of some [ __ ] like that your
value systems don't mean [ __ ]
yeah and like i said especially for some
you know for a race like this which
doesn't give a [ __ ] about you they just
they just have a good time they're
gleefully like just destroying the
planet because they want to you can't
negotiate with a crowd of people that
have already decided to kill you yeah
you're not you know
you can't negotiate yeah there was like
i said they were just like making a joke
about it yeah going around and like
[ __ ] you know don't run we are your
friends
so it's just kind of like the
warmongering trailer park dude in the
army
and then the [ __ ] new agey [ __ ]
airy fairy chick they both died no she
lived oh she lived yeah she is but her
friends got zapped yeah didn't and and
they were both wrong because i thought
they were here to save us
although i will say that she actually
twigged on pretty quick like as soon as
like she was just kind of killed one of
them yeah she didn't kill one of them so
she like why she turned over a new leaf
as soon as she saw well and i think
something that they didn't really go
into a lot because like i said there's
this is a huge cast and they don't
really go a lot into like character
building or anything like that
everyone's just very hastily drawn and
then it kind of goes back and forth like
to all these different characters they
didn't really hit on this too much but
she was um maybe the reason she was so
new agey airy fairy was she was a
recovering alcoholic
i mean they showed her in the aaa
meeting and so i'm guessing that that's
why she took on all these kind of new
age she believes because it was helping
her but then once she realized that the
martians were just there to kill
everybody she started drinking again
yeah that's right you know what i mean
and then she's like [ __ ] it and then she
started killing him so she actually did
end up living too danny devito tried to
barter his way out of it using his watch
because he was a lawyer and [ __ ] you
guys are going to need lawyers who are
going to take over the world
and he's like snapped the aliens it was
too late yeah
yeah yeah so yeah so i think the only
person that ended up living were
uh the guy um the guy from the casino
pam greer and their two kids they lived
uh the new agey
girl uh and that's boxer the yeah the
xbox guy that's who i met yeah and uh
tom jones and the girl the girl with the
amazing boobs
oh you have cindy her name was sandy and
the kid from the donut shop the brother
of uh jack black the army guy and the
and taffy yeah uh the daughter of the
president and first lady the cindy
character is from the casino and they
got her dressed up and grandma lived
cindy's from the casino and she's
dressed up as a cleopatra she runs
around through
half the half of the movie that
cleopatra had outfit [ __ ] as eye
candy she just yeah she doesn't hardly
get any lines but it's like i guess
she's just there for yeah she is an
actress though she did a bunch of other
movies yeah i know i'm just saying she
doesn't well she does get some lines
toward the end when they like when they
get the plane it was well known back
then i don't think yeah but and yeah
grandma lives i do i like at the end
like when her and uh her grandson are
giving their speeches because they're
getting the congressional medal medal of
honor from natalie portman uh because
she's the you know natalie portman's the
only member of the government that
survived and um and she's just and she
just like kind of pokes a natalie port
for the chest that don't let that happen
again
that was like so funny that was like the
same woman that was in beetlejuice that
was their uh caseworker um
i think this was her last movie actually
sylvia sydney her name is and i was like
reading an article about like some
behind the scenes stuff and like the
woman or the person that did the makeup
i think they said that she was a real
character they said she was like super
old and she was like a chain smoker and
it's like she always yelled at everybody
and she's like if um if you said
something she didn't like she'd always
say what are you an idiot
and i was like she sounds kind of
awesome
but yeah she was actually pretty funny
in this like she's the one with that
listens to the slim whitman and she also
has dementia but yeah but they were the
only ones that ended up living really
like out of everybody but yeah so mars
attacks you can rent it on
youtube you can rent on amazon prime but
at least as of this recording it is free
on tubey i don't know how long that's
going to be on there beetlejuice is on
there for free too
if you want to do like a tim burton
double feature for whatever reason uh so
yeah you can watch it for free at the
moment uh but you can stream it
elsewhere so
what do you guys think about mars
attacks like i said i know it's a little
bit of a divisive film in his catalog
and i'm curious as to what the uh
what the opinion of our of our listeners
is about it i always really really like
this movie it's not my favorite of his
um but it's definitely in the top three
or four i would say like i said edward
beetlejuice oh wait a minute maybe it's
top five edward scissorhands you know he
made a lot of good ones that's what i'm
saying but um but i always like really
enjoy this one and it's a lot of fun so
uh yeah let us know what you think about
it in the comments and that'll do it for
this movie retrospective we will see you
guys on the next one bye